but this is the point feminism in and of
itself can't be defended any idea the
point of an idea is that could be
defended by the people who believe in it
this is what the whole point of War
since the dawn of time it doesn't matter
if it's the Christians against the
Hindus doesn't matter if it was the
Germans against the French there were
people who had ideas and ideologies and
they're prepared to fight each other to
defend their ideology feminism is an
ideology which could not be defended by
feminists the only people who could
defend feminism are The Men Who
subscribe to the garbage with you it's
all the feminists were to get in a line
and say we want feminism and the
conservative men were to get in the line
you will learn very quickly it's